[Music]
a new warning today from nb energy
company leaders say a number of
complaints are coming in about scammers
offering rooftop solar and rebates
christian casara is joining us now with
how one local resident was able to
outsmart the thieves christian that's
right brian well matt kimball says this
call happened a while ago but he was
quickly able to spot the red flag he
said the scammer on the phone had his
correct name but an old address
i had someone cold call me ask if i was
interested in putting solar
on my residence las vegas resident matt
kimball says it takes a lot to scam him
but the fake calls are getting more
convincing it's a great way to save some
money on your energy bill
the problem is like it wasn't an nv
energy person calling me i had no idea
who they were it's the latest scam that
has nv energy's phones ringing non-stop
their spokesperson telling 8 news now
scammers are saying they are part of the
electric company to sell solar around
the valley they
pretty much were trying to either sell
me something or gain access to my place
of residence
which seemed a little odd for it to me
kimball says some red flags for him was
an old address they had and the person
on the phone was very persistent nv
energy is hoping this warning on social
media can help its customers be wary
also nv energy doesn't call customers to
demand immediate payment they also don't
accept payments via venmo or bitcoin
employees are prohibited from accepting
payments while in the field finally
service calls are by appointment only i
was not going to disclose to them that
you need to update your database because
you have the wrong address let them play
along with me and waste some of their
time honestly
well envy energy is reminding customers
that it does not partner with solar
providers now we have more tips on how
to avoid these scams on our website
christian
that's
is live local now